ich habe gerade die nachricht bekommen
dass wir vermutlich zugang zu einem der
höchsten gebäude in komplett köln haben
und damit eine menge geld schützen
können wieso das wichtig ist und wie wir
mit höhe geld verdienen können seht ihr
in diesem video aber erstmal zurück das
hier ist ein router und dieses ding
verspricht wie viele andere sachen die
es in diesem format schon getestet habe
ohne aktive arbeit geld holen zu können
geld verdienen ohne etwas dafür zu tun
gewinne von über 1000 prozent und dabei
noch teil einer innovativen bewegung
seien natürlich rede ich kontakte und
nachdem wir auf diesem kanal schon
crypto gehandelt haben und auch selber
eine kontoführung erstellt haben wird es
zeit für etwas neues viel spaß mit durch
helium mining zu rolex
bevor wir anfangen riesiges schau dort
anton pletzer der gerade auch ein helium
projekt macht und mich dazu inspiriert
hat das projekt wieder aufzunehmen und
damit anzufangen aber was zur hölle ist
helium einigen jeder von uns nutzt das
internet egal ob wlan oder mobile da
aber nicht nur die persönliche nutzen
das internet sondern auch alle möglichen
sachen die draußen in der stadt herum
stehen also parkautomaten digitale
busstationen und alles was dann noch so
kommen mag das alles zusammen oder
internet of things diese sachen brauchen
eben eine verbindung momentan ist man
bei all diesen sachen noch auf mobilfunk
anbieter angewiesen und genau hier kommt
helium endspiel die degewo ein
dezentrales netzwerk aus routern auf der
gesamten welt aufzuziehen bei dem die
mutter von leuten wie dir und mir
aufgestellt werden um im besten fall ein
lückenloses netz auf der gesamten welt
zu haben wie zur hölle verdient man
damit aber jetzt geld dafür ein neues
gebiet mit netz abgedeckt zu haben wird
man mit helium krokus belohnt je mehr
fläche man abdeckt und je mehr andere
router man erreicht desto mehr tokens
werden ausgeschüttet wenn man seinen
router also in einem gebiet auf stellt
in dem schon ein guter stehen das also
schon erschlossen ist muss man sich dem
report mit diesen anderen gut anteilen
verdient also weniger geld es gilt also
möglichst neue gebiete zu erschließen es
gibt da allerdings noch ein paar
probleme die router sind so beliebt dass
sie natürlich überall ausverkauft sind
schlecht dazu hört das aber bei den
routern nicht auf und man braucht auch
die richtige antenne in kombination mit
dem richtigen placement also den
richtigen standort wo man den router
aufstellen und gleichzeitig gibt es noch
eine menge leute die behaupten dass ein
ponzi scheme sei also komplett das game
probleme sind da um sie zu lösen wir
lösen die und wenn im besten fall gut
dafür entlohnt vergesst nicht den kanal
zu abonnieren ich will dieses jahr ja
noch ne halbe millionen abonnenten
knacken wenn ich das video gefällt weil
ich die anderen videos gefallen und wir
kennt man verpassen wollt dann durch den
abo button und support nicht bevor ich
mich aber darum gekümmert habe ein
router zu kaufen hier ist es erstmal
informationen sammeln erst mal ein
bisschen in das thema rein fuchsen und
sehen wo sind die hürden und was kann
ich machen um den gewinnen möglichst zu
maximieren und auch super für recherche
und zeit die ich vorher schon investiert
habt hieß es irgendwann endlich meiner
kaufen also habe ich mich auf die suche
gemacht und direkt gesehen dass sie
natürlich über preis gehandelt werden
originale haben die eigentlich mal so um
die 400 euro gekostet gehandelt werden
sie für über 1.000 euro glücklicherweise
gab es in köln aber ein händler dennoch
mehrere zum verkauf hat
es kommen nur wegen ihm ein großteil
nicht das ist die große frage ich würde
man mit einem staaten oder zu machen
oder weil sie sich ja sagen kann ja auch
mal überlegt da man hier kann ich
sowieso also musste außerhalb gehen was
willst du dafür haben noch nach draußen
oder 1000 euro ist am preis noch etwas
zu machen wie so häufig also eine idee
bei der man auch ziemlich groß anfangs
investment angewiesen ist und genau hier
kommt ein bisschen spiel sagen das gibt
euch die möglichkeit anteile eurer
lieblings collectibles zu kaufen und
diese auf zu handeln so könnt ihr also
anteile von luxusuhren sneakern
kunstwerk aus figur im hintergrund und
super vielen anderen dingen kaufen ohne
den kompletten preis alleine zahlen zu
müssen das macht es einfacher habt das
macht sicherer und was ist außerdem sich
hat ist es time lässt sich um die
lagerung und versicherung von all diesen
sachen gemacht ihr müsst euch also keine
sorgen um die kollekte bild machen von
denen ihr anteil erhaltet ihr müsst im
prinzip nichts machen außer anteile zu
kaufen und diese zu verkaufen wann immer
ihr wollt über den ersten linken der
video beschreibung bekommt ihr 10 euro
startguthaben mit ihr euch direkt einen
kostenlosen anteil eines mieters sichern
könnt weil dieser anteil genau zehn euro
kurs in den kommenden wochen gruppen
immer wieder krank produkte wie nächste
woche wo eine gmp master pepsi kommt und
ihr davon anteile kaufen könnt momentan
ist es sogar möglich anteile vom erhalt
oder von dem tokyo bank zu kaufen also
es sind immer wieder neue geile produkte
an denen man sich beteiligen kann autos
wein kunst sneaker uhren so ziemlich
alles was ihr euch vorstellen könnt ich
bedanke mich vielmals vertreiben ist
dass die mich um dieses projekt zu
unterstützen und freue mich sehr dass
wir zusammen gefunden haben checkt den
ersten ligen in der video beschreibung
aus meldet euch an fangt an zu
investieren und ich werde es auch viel
spaß weiter mit es ist tatsächlich
passiert nach über anderthalb wochen
informationen sammeln recherchieren im
internet hin und her gucken habe ich
meinen ersten helium einer gekauft
und das ist es also der 1000 euro guter
meiner mit dem wir hoffentlich sehr viel
geld verdienen können und das ist drin
einmal den router eine antenne die wir
voraussichtlich austauschen werden um
ein stromkabel das war's das war's um
dieses ding alleine soll uns anscheinend
bis zu 500 euro im monat bringen wenn
ich eine richtige location finde da bin
ich sehr gespannt und bevor ich den
router also jetzt einfach wahllos
installieren müssen wir erst schauen ob
wir überhaupt einen platz finden wo wir
denn hin stellen können er muss
möglichst hoch sein möglichst freie
sicht haben und irgendwo sein wo noch
kein anderer steht man wird dann auch
belohnt inwieweit man dazu beiträgt das
netz weiter auszubauen und zu stärken je
höher der mutter liegt desto eher kann
er über störende hindernisse wie gebäude
hinweg senden bestenfalls steht der
router in einem bis dato nicht
erschlossenen gebiet wo er trotz alledem
mit möglichst vielen anderen routern
kommuniziert unser idealer platz um
unseren gewinn zu maximieren liegt also
möglichst hoch möglichst frei und in
ideale entfernung zu anderen gut
glücklicherweise gibt es mittlerweile
eine menge programme mit denen man all
diese standorte simulieren kann und
schon vorher grob abschätzen kann wie
viel man an welchem standort verdient
und natürlich habe ich genau das getan
wir sehen hier schon so liane hexagone
die geben den bereich an in dem wir
keinen weiteren router aufstellen
sollten weil wir uns sonst den report
teilen müssen hier ist beispielsweise
nur einer drin der kriegt das gesamte
geld was dann in diesem bereich gemeint
wird wenn wir weiter in die innenstadt
gehen sehen wir aber hexagone
multiplikator von 0,25 was bedeutet dass
das geld in diesem hexagon durch vier
geteilt wird was schlecht ist das
bedeutet wir können quasi komplett
vergessen hier in der innenstadt
irgendwas aufzustellen weil hier schon
alles belegt ist ein tag später eine
große antenne es bestellt und ich habe
jetzt wirklich vier oder fünf spots die
ein absoluter traum sind und ein spot
davon ist das wohnhaus von einem kumpel
formieren das bedeutet ist deutlich
einfacher reinzukommen als andere
hochhäuser wo ich niemanden kenne ruhig
bei den fremden leuten klingeln muss und
fragen muss ob ich bei denen eine fette
antenne ans haus hängen kann also habe
ich sofort meine sieben sachen gepackt
und bin zum haus gefahren komplett wie
immer habe ich angefangen die antenne
aufzubauen und schaut euch das mal an
über 50 meter hoch komplett freie sicht
und eine super kraftvoller antenne
liefern bis nach düsseldorf strahlen
kann also wirklich ein riesiger bereich
in dem eine menge andere helium meiner
stehen mit denen wir uns connection
können und mit denen wir gemeinsam das
netz ausbauen eine simulation von diesem
sport hat ergeben dass wir bis zu
1500 euro im monat mit diesem spot
verdienen können jetzt ist es also nur
noch füße hochlegen das ding für uns
arbeiten lassen und reich werden oder
vielleicht auch nicht mein helium einer
hat genau einen tag gemeint es ist
wirklich eine absolute scheiße seit vier
tagen probiert er sich wieder zurück auf
die blogs chain zu connecten was nötig
ist damit wir geld verdienen und so wie
es gerade aussieht wird das auch noch
für die nächsten 30 stunden so sein und
in dieser kompletten zeit verdienen wir
kein geld in dieser kompletten zeit
steht der männer an der quasi perfekten
position mitten in köln könnte mega
umsatz bringen aber es passiert nichts
parallel dazu steigt die krippe währung
um fast 100 prozent auf über 40 eur von
20 und wir verdienen nichts also ist es
wirklich eine absolute scheiße ich habe
mich extra mit jemandem in verbindung
gesetzt der mehr ahnung hat als ich der
schon über 30 crypto meine aufgestellt
hat also 30 helium meiner und er hat
auch keinen rat er sagt manchmal ist es
einfach so und es dauert aber ich kann
es nicht mehr abwarten man gibt es so
ein bisschen aus der hand und das ding
muss einfach machen ich hoffe dass es
jetzt in 30 stunden dann wirklich
vernünftig connected ist und für uns
jeden tag aufs neue wieder geld
verdienen kann passiv es soll einfach
jetzt funktionieren
in dieser folge also über 1000 euro
verlust gemacht oder nein wir haben
sogar über 2000 euro verlust gemacht
denn ich bin danach sofort losgefahren
und habe einen zweiten männer gekauft
weil ich wirklich daran glaubt wir
werden das in den nächsten wochen also
weiter begleiten und unser netzwerk aus
helium mein land weiter ausbauen
vergessen also nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren wenn ihr kleinster folgende
videos verpassen wollt lassen wir die
einen like damit es euch gefallen hat
und dann sehen wir uns am donnerstag
wieder macht gut
[Musik]